And in the morning, rising up a great
while before a day, he went out and
departed into a solitary place, and
there prayed. Mark 1:35.
Welcome to Q&A with Elder Randy Ski on
the Word inspired. I'm your host, Dr.
miracle and today we are talking about
the devotional life of the remnant.
Before we go any further, let's have a
word of prayer. Father, thank you for
this holy Sabbath day where we can learn
of you and commune with you. And as dear
Lord, we learn about how to have a
closer walk with you day by day. Be with
us. I pray that you would fill your
man's servant, Elder Randy Sket, with
your words of life, your words of power,
your Holy Spirit, so that every answer
he gives is straight from your throne.
This is my prayer. In Jesus's name, I
pray.
>> Amen.
>> All right. Well, brothers and sisters,
while the world is celebrating
Valentine's Day, we celebrate the God
who gave his only begotten son
>> out of love. for [clears throat] us when
we hated him. Praise God for his example
of love. And today we want to learn
about how to have a closer walk with the
father. And to answer the questions on
this topic, we have none other than the
renowned and yet humble elder Randy SK.
Amen. who has studied for the ministry
at the Oakwood University and the
theological seminary at Andrews
University and spends his time improving
his craft for the Lord and studying the
word of God and
God's works through nature so that any
person he comes in contact with whether
they be atheists, archaeologists,
astronauts, scientists, he can share a
word that will lead them to the God of
Please give Elder Rainey Ski a warm
virtual welcome.
>> Thank you very much my dear daughter.
It's nice to see you and all those who
were joining us online wherever you may
be on this world of ours. May the Lord
bless you. Thank you for your interest
in truth. And as Denanisha said, this is
Valentine's Day for the secular world.
But God demonstrated his valentine long
ago by sending his son Jesus Christ. The
greatest gift that has ever been given,
the most expensive and the one which is
the basis upon which we can receive any
blessing from God and that basis is
Jesus Christ. So again, I am seriously
and genuinely delighted and honored to
be a part of this program. And may the
spirit of God speak through me and
through you that we may all leave
blessed, enlightened, edified, but above
all, God glorified through this program.
>> Amen and amen.
All right. Well, I don't know, Elder
Ski, if you want to say a prayer before
we get into the class.
>> Yes. All right. I will surely.
>> Yes. Our father in heaven, we thank you
for James chapter 1 verse 5. If any of
you lack wisdom, let him ask of God that
giveth to all men liberally and
upgradeth not, and it shall be given
him. Grant to us that wisdom, I pray,
that whatever we say may make the truth
clearer, plainer, and more attractive in
the name of Jesus Christ. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question
is what does devotion refer to in the
Christian's life? What does it consist
of? And why is it relevant for God's
people living in the last days? So what
does devotion refer to?
>> Let's look at the word devotion. And
immediately we see the word devote. To
devote is to give yourself entirely to
something or to someone. You may be
devoted to democracy. Someone may be
devoted to peace. Someone may be devoted
to basketball. Someone devoted to the
pursuit of some area of physics. Devote
to devote is to give yourself fully to
someone or to something. Then devotion
in the biblical sense has three major
components. One, it is a total surrender
of the self to God. And when I say the
self, I mean everything that makes up
the self is given to God. As Jesus said,
"Thou shalt love the Lord thy God with
all thy heart, with all thy soul, with
all thy mind, with all thy strength."
The second component is obedience to
this person to whom you've devoted
yourself. And the third component is the
disciplined life you live that reflects
and honors the one to whom you've
devoted yourself. So all of that
constitutes the devotional life of the
Christian. Then we will get into how do
I exercise that disciplined life? What
is the power necessary to do that? And
then we'll get into the Bible and prayer
and other activities. But devotion is
essentially the surrender of oneself.
Not only a momentary act, but that
devotion is a lifestyle. So that I'm
praying whether I'm kneeling or not. I'm
thinking of God no matter what I'm
doing. God is always on my mind. I'm
always trying to please him. This is a
devotional life. Now, of course, we come
to a more um narrow experience in
devotion where someone is in a room
praying and setting the word. That's a
devotional act. Yes. But is more than an
act. It is an entire mindset. I exist
for the glory of God. And everything I
do, I will try to direct glory to God
and not do anything to embarrass him.
This is living a devotional life. Not
simply a monk in a mountain somewhere
with no contact with anyone. That's not
what I'm talking about. I mean active
practical life prayer study and of
course reflecting Jesus Christ in all
that you do and in your interaction with
people.
>> Powerful. Powerful understand question
was why is it important in the last
days? Is that part of the question?
Okay.
>> Yes, it is. Well, the Bible tells us
we're coming to a time of severe
trouble.
We're saved by faith. We're judged by
works. You know, Jesus tells us, "This
people honor me with their lips, but
their hearts are far from me." It is not
what we say that's the essence of
devotion. It's what's contained in the
mind or the heart of the person. We need
a relationship with God based on his
word that is so secure that regardless
of the trials coming and they are
coming. We will remain steadfast in our
relationship with God. Nothing will
shake us. As in the case of Daniel and
the three Hebrew boys, they were devoted
to God. Totally devoted to the point
where their lives were not as important
as honoring God. As in the case of Paul
in Acts 20, he said, "I do not count my
life there unto me that I might finish
my work and the ministry that God has
given to me." So that his commitment to
God took precedence over his own life.
This is the devotion we need in order to
get ready to go through the time of
trouble is coming. And it is a time of
trouble. We cannot anticipate the
dimensions of the horror that that are
coming for us. And so we need a
connection with God that Gethsemane or
Calvary cannot shake.
>> Help us Lord.
>> You look death right in the eye and you
say glory to God. You look death right
in the eye and with a blinking you say
glory to God because God's glory, God's
honor is more important than your very
life. And I'm not speaking symbolically.
I am speaking literally.
>> It's like John Hus when he was on that
stake he was singing
>> singing to the Lord worshiping.
>> You know one point that I want to
underscore Elder Sket is that our
devotion is not an isolated part of our
lives. It is our lives. It
>> is our lifestyle. Powerful. Powerful.
>> All right. Our next question is, what
can we learn from the devotional life of
John the Baptist? And how did his
devotional life shape the messages he
shared?
>> John by God's direction spent his adult
life in the wilderness
where clearly God taught him, the Holy
Ghost taught him. He was away from the
influences of the city and the society.
His diet was very uh spare so that his
spirituality could develop not
influenced by secular uh activities or
secular environments.
With that constant exposure to God, John
could come forth. Keep in mind that John
the Baptist knew he would be going forth
as a prophet, the first prophet since
Malachi. The Jews had not had a prophet
for 400 years. They had gone through uh
the rulership of the the Persians. Then
they went through the rulership of the
Seucids. They went through the rulership
and they were under the Romans now. And
they were waiting and waiting for a
prophet of the Messiah. John knew when
he stepped out he might be a sensation.
Here is the very first prophet since
Malachi approximately 400 years. And he
knew his message would not be get rid of
the Romans. His message would be repent.
That's a tough message to all the people
who are under subjugation to foreign
power. What they want to hear is set us
free. Even the disciples of Christ
expected that from him. But his message
was Matthew chapter 3. Repent ye for the
kingdom of heaven is at hand. And so
John had to be prepared spiritually. his
devotional life strengthened him and
gave him the spiritual spine to stand up
against the prevailing forces of his day
and to deliver the simple message
repent. You know the Jews thought that
repentance was the Gentiles. You know
they were God's people. They were fine.
John is telling them you repent. And so
he had to have had a preparation, an
unusual preparation before he could come
out and preach that message to uh to the
people. Eventually, of course, we know
he got his head cut off. And so John's
devotional life prepared him for a very
very demanding task. The first prophet
in 400 years. And his message was not
get rid of the Romans. It was you Jews
need to repent.
There was a second part to the question.
>> Yes. The second part was how did his
devotional life shape the messages you
shared which you touched on.
>> Okay. All right. Well, you see in his
interaction with God in the wilderness,
the Lord clearly told him what to say,
how to say, when to say. We have to
believe all of that took place. So that
John Elite said you John, if you look at
the preachers in the New Testament, John
was the boldest, the most direct perhaps
other than Jesus Christ. And Ellen White
tells us in the last days just before
Christ has succumbed the second time,
God's faithful messengers are to bear a
still more pointed testimony than was
born than John the Baptist. John the
Baptist was direct. He was blunt. He
polished nothing. He came straight
between the eyes. And you need a
spiritual connection with God which is
developed through devotion to deliver
that kind of message with that kind of
boldness having no concern for your own
life. And so yes, his devotional life
prepared him and also shaped the message
because the message was direct. Repent.
That was his message. Repent. And he was
preparing the way for the Messiah to
come who also said repent. And so yes,
his devotional life prepared him and his
message was very very simply repent.
Your problem is not really the Romans.
Your problem is sin. And you cannot
preach that to the Jews back then.
That's not an easy message to preach.
>> Indeed. Indeed. As John prepared the way
for Christ
>> in his first advent, we also need to be
preparing the way for
>> the second advent. That's right.
>> For the second advent
>> with more boldness than John.
>> Amen. And it is possible. I'll just read
this quotation here from last day
events, page 63, paragraph 1. And it
says, "In this age, just prior to the
second coming of Christ in the clouds of
heaven, such a work as that of John is
to be done."
>> Okay?
>> God calls for men who will prepare
people to stand in the great day of God
in order to give such a message as John
gave. We must have a spiritual
experience. Mhm. Mhm. You know, before
God sent Moses to lead Israel, a very
difficult task, he kept him in the
wilderness 40 years to prepare him for
that task. So that Moses now can do his
work boldly and fearlessly. The greatest
preacher other than Christ Paul. In
order to prepare him, God took him into
the Arabian desert for three years to
prepare him because his message which
scandalized the Jews. You read Romans,
the the text on righteousness by faith.
In chapter one, Paul says that Gentiles
need Jesus. In chapter two, Paul says
the Jews need Jesus. So, he put them on
the same level. That's not an easy thing
to say to the Jews. And so, Paul had to
have a spe had to have had a very very
special preparation with God in the
wilderness in order to emerge and preach
uh that kind of message very similar to
the preparation that John the Baptist
received. And of course before that
Moses received there must be that time
where it's just you and God for an
extended period of time that he may
shape you, prepare you for the task
ahead. And as a people, we're being
shaped and prepared for the time of
trouble that's coming right at the door
by the way.
>> Amen. Amen. May we embrace the
wilderness experience of God's grace.
>> Amen.
Now we will transition. I will invite my
dear sister, attorney Alana Kashi,
>> okay,
>> to ask the next three questions. Thank
you so much for joining all the way from
Rhode Island. Sister
>> Rhode Island. [clears throat]
>> Yes, thank you so much and happy Sabbath
and again um Elder Skied for coming on
and answering some of our questions. So
going back to what you were saying with
you know the consistent preparation
that's needed. My question is what are
ways we can be consistent in our
devotion to God without it becoming
monotonous
>> without becoming monotonous.
>> Yes.
>> Second Peter chapter 3 18 tells us grow
in grace. Monotony
clearly tells us there's no growth. It's
all the same. Where there is growth,
there cannot be monotony. So, we're told
grow in grace and in the knowledge of
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. Second
Peter 3:18. The principal purpose of
devotion is to become more and more like
the savior. To learn more of him, to
expose yourself to his grace, his glory,
that in some way the light of his glory
may shine in our faces as it did on the
face of Moses. And so devotion is
interaction with God. I mean the key,
the kernel, there's the public part of
devotion. But that which serves as the
spinal cord, the foundation stone is
that personal time as Dr. Nishio read
that text in Mark that Jesus went off
into place by himself. That's the most
important part of devotion, your time
with God. And that time is taken up with
prayer and the study of the word of God.
It cannot be simply praying because if
all you do is prayer, at some point you
will cease to pray or your prayers
become monotonous. It is prayer and
study and you leave that individual time
with God to carry out in your life what
he has taught you in that private
moment. And so that cannot produce uh
boredom or monotony. It produces an
active growth in the life of the
Christian because he or she is driven by
the consciousness I am to grow in grace.
I was put on this earth as far back as
Adam to reflect the image of God. And
since the image of God is infinite, I
must grow and grow and grow and grow.
And there's no monotony in constant
growth. And so the word of God studied
and obeyed. It is in the obedience that
the growth takes place. So study of the
word, obedience of the word and of
course constant prayer to God. that and
of then of course in in the in the
public side of devotion interacting with
others that they may see Christ in you
and that you may talk of your savior
when the occasion presents itself.
>> Thank you. Um, and so talking about
having that continue doing the word of
God, I mean studying the word of God and
continued prayer and all
>> and everything else that must be done
within the devotional life
>> of us as you know Christians, us as
young people, us as people who follow um
the shepherd. My next question is Ellen
White writes, "Believers must now be
firmly rooted in Christ or else they
will be led astray by some phase of
error." And this is from last day events
64 um 64 I think it's line three.
>> Okay.
>> How do we root ourselves in Christ and
remain rooted throughout the day?
All of creation was designed to keep God
always on the mind. Let me say that
again. From creation that day one light
to land animals and people, all of
creation, one of his functions is to
keep God always on the mind. So many you
ask, how can that devotion go through
the day? Wherever you turn, wherever you
look up, down, right, or left, you see
something that should remind you of God.
The Bible tells us in Psalm 19:1, the
heavens declare the glory of God. The
glory of God is his character. Uh 2
Chron uh Corinthians 3:18,
God's amazing ga grace. Page 325,
paragraph 2, God's 325, paragraph 2. You
look at a tree, you think of God. Look
at the sky, God. You look at an animal,
God. A person, God. You feel the wind,
God. All of that is designed to keep God
on the mind. Now, of course, what's more
powerful than that is the actual
application of the word. What you study,
you obey. And so, you go through life
literally, and this may sound extreme.
Will this glorify God? It's the constant
question. In John 8:29, the Bible says,
"And he that is with me, he that have
sent me is with me. The Father hath not
left me alone, for I do always those
things that please him. When you read
that literally, you must conclude that
Jesus day by day lived a life of a
continual fast. What was that fast? He
fasted from self. The only way he could
say, "I do always those things that
please him is because he fasted from
self." Not that he did not have his own
mind. He did. He did not have his own
desires. He did. But ultimately what
pleased the father is what dominated his
thinking. We must develop that kind of
mind. If I'm a doctor, I'm a dentist,
I'm an architect, I'm a bus driver,
whatever I do, am I considering the
glory of God in not only what I do, but
how I do it? So if I see a client as a
lawyer, where is the glory of God in
this interaction? You know if I'm a
doctor, if I'm a teacher, if I'm a
pilot, where is the glory of God? And we
take this expression, do all to the
glory of God. We take it very lightly,
but it is literal. There is no area of
the life, casual or serious, behind
closed doors or in public, that should
escape all for the glory of God. When we
live that way, my sister, we become
closer and because God realizes that he
is our priority. But for many of us, we
say something with the lips, but the
heart is something else. And God sees
that the life of the believer is for the
glory of God
in everything he or she does. I've
sometimes said, and some people laugh,
there's a way for a Christian to play
basketball that glorifies God. There's a
way to go skiing that glorifies God.
There's a way to go for a walk in nature
that glorifies God. They are no
exception. That is why you know Elise
said the difference between believer and
unbeliever should be as great as the
difference between light and darkness.
But as it is, it's difficult to tell the
difference between believer and the
world because we're so much alike. But a
life of devotion is a life that produces
a difference that is stark in stark
contrast to the life of the unbeliever.
In everything we do and we see, we look
for God. We look for God. If you uh
you're in a city, you think of the new
Jerusalem. You know, you're out in the
country, you think of nature. Wherever
you are, whatever you do, the clothes
you wear, is it cotton? Who made the
trees? Are your shoes leather? Who made
the cows? You discipline the mind. God,
God, God at all times. And again, I am
not speaking symbolically. I am speaking
literally. But that kind of life gets
you in trouble with the church. It
really, really does. But that's the life
God requires. That's the life Jesus
lived. His father always on his mind.
>> Thank you. And just to agree with you,
Sister White says that the greatest
battles, the battle against self. And so
having our minds on Christ is always,
always, always important.
>> You know what the Bible says?
>> Mhm.
>> Thou will keep him in perfect peace
whose mind is stayed upon thee. Stayed
for how long? Five minutes a day. Who,
if that's the case, the mind is not
stayed on God. Thou will keep him in
perfect peace. whose mind is stayed upon
thee. What does the Bible tell us in
Psalm 1 verse two? And in his law does
he meditate day and night. The heavenly
lifestyle is an unusual lifestyle. But
this is the lifestyle that would impact
the world. Not a lifestyle that is
worldly. A truly heavenly lifestyle.
That's a devotional life that God
requires of us.
>> Thank you. And so my last question is,
what changes should we expect to see as
we have true and constant communion with
God?
>> Excellent question.
>> Yes.
>> Excellent question, my dear sister. One,
a a gradual distaste for the things of
the world. You find yourself more and
more losing interest. You don't care if
there's a Super Bowl. You don't care
about the National Basketball Associ.
You just don't care. these things cease
to mean anything to you because that is
the world. You know, there's a text that
says that which is highly esteemed among
men is abomination with God. You look at
when people win an Oscar, how they cry
and they greet their parents and the
Bible says that which is highly esteemed
among men is abomination with God.
Someone wins an NBA championship, he
kisses the trophy, falls on the ground,
cries, and you think of the verse that
which is highly esteemed among men is
abomination with God. The Olympics are
going on now. The Winter Olympics in
Italy. People are rejoicing. If God got
a gold medal, that which is highly
esteemed among men is abomination with
God. And so what you begin to see is a
change in your mindset toward the things
of the world. What the world values is
of no importance to you at all. What
you'll begin to notice is a love for the
word of God, a love for prayer, a love
for fellowship with God's people, a love
for being in God's house, worshiping
God. These things become apparent as you
change. It does not happen overnight,
but constant exposure to the word of
God. The divine radiation will gradually
remove the worldly leaning of your mind
and give you a mind that is totally
heavenly. As Paul says, if ye then be
risen with Christ, seek those things
which are above, where Christ siteth on
the right hand of God. Set your
affections on things above.
Set your affection. What is it you love?
What is it really appeals to you? Set
your affection on things above. There
are Christians in quotation mark who
can't wait for the Sabbath to pass so
they can do what they have to do. Their
affections are not set on things above.
When your affection is set on things
above, spiritual things attract you more
than anything else. Even though you live
a practical life, you go to work, you go
to the gym, whatever, but spiritual
things has the greatest appeal for you.
And that change comes upon you gradually
as you grow and you become more and more
like Jesus Christ. How does that take
place? The study of the word, obedience
to the word, prayer, and sharing your
faith when occasion permits it.
>> So it's right to say that the person who
so the person who works on these changes
in us is not just ourselves. only Holy
Ghost that's empowering that change. But
it is done in cooperation with you and
me. You see, you look at John 3:16. For
God so loved the world, that's God. He
did not need my permission to love the
world that he gave his only begotten
son. He did not need my permission that
whosoever believeth. So we have God
giving but I believing. So there is a
division of labor if labor is the right
word. Salvation is not something that
does not require our involvement at all.
Only God can save. Yes. But he does that
saving if we cooperate with him. It's
like going to the dentist. You want the
the the the cavity taken care of. Open
your mouth. Open it up and open wide and
leave it open until I tell you close it.
So, we must cooperate with God. So, yes,
the power that drives the growth is the
word of God and the Holy Spirit. But God
will not study the word for you. He will
not need it down pray for you. You've
got to study. You've got to pray. And as
you do it sincerely, a change inevitably
takes place. And I use the word
inevitably takes place. But after
consistent exposure to the very power
that created heaven and earth, the power
that raised Lazarus, the power that will
raise the righteous dead. That's the
power of the word. And when you expose
yourself to that word, it changes you
day by day, moment by moment.
By the way, you expose yourself to the
world. It will remove that spiritual
work.
>> Yes. Thank you so much for answering my
question.
>> You're welcome. You're welcome.
>> I'll hand it back over to my sister.
>> All right.
>> Thank you so very much, Elis and my
sister, Attorney Quashi.
>> Yes.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. So let
us ask our next two questions which will
culminate the official questions for
this session before we transition to our
open forum segment.
What must prayer and the study of God's
word be coupled with to complete the
devotional life of the remnant?
>> Obedience.
Obedience. The whole thing is obedience.
You see, if Adam had simply obeyed, you
and I would not be in this condition.
we'd be in heaven somewhere or the new
world somewhere to touring the universe.
The simple thing is you look at the Adam
and Eve were put out because of
disobedience. The very last chapter of
the last book of the Bible, Revelation
22:14, blessed are they that do his
commandments that they may have a right.
You lost the right through disobedience.
You regain it through spirit empowered
obedience. We need no help from God to
disobey. We need help from God to obey.
But it does not change the fact
obedience.
The power of God is released through the
word through obedience. So you study,
you study, you study, then what? Apply
it. Obey it. You pray, you pray, you
pray, then what? When God speaks to you
in the prayer and he instructs you, what
do you do? So the key is obedience.
The Bible tells you what to do. The
spirit gives you the power to do it, but
the decision to do it is yours. And that
has to be a constant decision. Constant
decision. And so it is obedience, my
dear daughter. Obedience. That's the
key.
But you know the carnal nature hates the
word obedience with concentrated venom.
It hates the word obedience. But that is
the key word.
That's why Jesus said, "If you love me
and love is devotion." You see, if you
love me, if you devoted to me, and we're
discussing devotion. If you devoted to
me, obey me.
Obedience proves devotion,
not talk. Obedience proves devotion.
And I mean microscopic obedience.
That's not that's not legalism. When God
told Noah to build the ark, Noah had no
recommendations for the dimensions. God
gave him the dimensions. He had to
follow every single detail. When God
gave Moses instructions for the building
of the tabernacle, he had to follow the
hundreds of little detail. He could not
change one. That required strict
absolute obedience. Do exactly what I
say. That's the way a devoted person
lives. A person devoted to God. Whatever
God says, I do.
Jesus said out of himself, by the way,
as the father gave me commandments, so I
do. John 14:31.
As the father gave me commandment, so I
do.
No negotiation.
>> No negotiation. Total surrender.
>> Total surrender.
>> You know, I say if we would be as
surrendered to God as Jesus was, the
power expressed in Christ would be
expressed in us.
>> A devotional, a devote, a person devoted
to God is not just a decent person. You
don't need God to be decent. I always
say most atheists I believe are very
decent and law-abiding. We're not
discussing decency. Even though decency
will be a part of the Christian life,
don't misunderstand me. We're discussing
devotion.
I live for him. I work for him. I
breathe for him.
He is the result that the purpose why
I'm alive.
He's my purpose for living his glory.
That's the devoted person. That's the
key of devotional life. God, God, God.
That's why the angels say, "Holy, holy,
holy day and night. Day and night."
Praise God. Praise God. I'll just read
this quote that brother Israel joining
from Ghana put in the chat. You have
studied studied and obeyed. Mhm.
>> The word of God works in the hearts.
>> Yes.
>> Every unholy entry.
>> Every single one.
>> Give the audience the location of that
quotation.
>> Ah, I believe it's education.
>> No, no, no. Christ subject lessons page
100 paragraph one.
>> It might be an education as well. Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, no. I think I'm thinking of, you
know, higher than the humus uh yes.
That's right. That's right. That's
right.
>> That's education. I believe page 18.
>> Yes. Yes. Mhm.
>> All right. So,
>> God bless Ghana, by the way.
>> Yes. Amen.
Amen. All right. Our next question.
>> In what ways does a deep devotional life
build our love for God and truth? And
why is that love of the truth especially
vital now?
>> But if you read, go to 2 Thessalonians
chapter 2. Yeah, you have your Bible
chapter 2. We'll read from verse 9 and
we'll try to read carefully and
microscopically.
Second Thessalonians. Now, in this
chapter, Paul is discussing the man of
sin, which is another term for the
little horn of Daniel 7. And of course,
uh the the the the beast in in
Revelation 13. That's who Paul is
referring to. Here's what Paul says. 2
Thessalonians 2, we read from verse 9.
Let me pray again. Day God as we
continue grant all of us wisdom
enlightenment I pray bless everyone
listening in Jesus name. Amen. Read from
verse n whose coming is after the
working of Satan.
>> Yes with even him whose coming is after
the working of Satan with all power and
signs and lying wondershu
>> and with all deceivleness of
unrighteousness in them that perish.
>> Uhhuh. because they received not the
love of the truth.
>> Okay, now you've got to love the truth.
Now, don't lose that passage. We're
coming back to it. Keep a finger on that
passage. Go to John 8. Let's look at the
the mindset of a carnal person
until that person meets Christ. John 8,
we read 80 44 and 45 of John 8.
Actually, we go to 46. John 8 44 to 46.
Let's read. Year of your father. are of
Yes. Ye are of your father the devil and
the lusts of your father ye will do.
>> He was a murderer from the beginning and
abode not in the truth because there is
no truth in him. When he speaketh, he
speaketh a lie. He speaketh of his own.
For he is a liar and the father of it.
>> Now we pause right there now. Take a
deep breath. Listen to 45 and see the
sadness in that verse. Read 45. And
>> because I tell you the truth,
>> uh-huh,
>> ye believe me not.
>> People refuse to believe something just
because it's true.
It's a terrible indictment of the carnal
mind. That the truth is hated just
because it's true.
The frightening conclusion is the carnal
mind prefers a lie.
Is anybody listening to me? The carnal
nature prefers lies.
Jesus said, "You refuse to believe me."
Why? Because what I'm saying is true.
The carnal unconverted mind does not
like truth.
Which means it prefers lies. Now read
verse 46.
>> Which of you convincth me of sin?
>> Mhm. And if I say the truth, why do ye
not believe me?
>> Yes.
Why don't you believe the truth?
>> Now, let's go back to 2 Thessalonians
chapter 2. Pick it up from verse 10.
>> And with all deceivleness of
unrighteousness in them that perish
>> because they receive not the love of the
truth that they might be saved.
>> Notice they did not receive. We must ask
God to give us a love for truth. A love
for truth is not a natural function of
the carnal nature. That has to be given
to us from an outside source and that
source is Christ himself who is the
truth. The father is the truth. The Holy
Ghost is the truth. They did not receive
the love. You have to love truth. You
can love the church and not love truth.
And that is widespread around the world.
The Bible says they are condemned. They
will perish because they did not love
the truth. Keep reading. [snorts]
And for this cause
>> God shall send them strong delusions.
>> Yes.
>> That they should believe a lie.
>> Uhhuh. Who
>> that they Yeah. That they all might be
damned who believed not the truth but
had pleasure in unrighteousness.
>> Now look at that. They believed not the
truth. They had pleasure in
unrighteousness. Give me another word
for unrighteousness. Notice Jesus said,
"Believe not the truth." but had
pleasure in unrighteousness. We can say
believe not the truth but had pleasure
in sin. The opposite of truth in that
context. And so in verse 10, they
receive not the love of the truth. And
in verse verse 12, I think it is they
did not believe the truth.
And so you must love truth even if it's
inconvenient. A lot of people refuse the
Sabbath commandment because it is
inconvenient. But love for truth is not
hampered by inconvenience, not even by
life itself. If it's true, I go for it.
That that love for truth must be given
to us from above. As we study the word
of God and expose ourselves to
concentrated truth, God infuses us with
the love for truth more. And as we
practice that truth through obedience,
the love for truth grows and grows and
grows. And so Job said, "I have esteemed
the words of thy mouth more than my
necessary food." And the words of God's
mouth are words of truth. Jesus said, "I
have meat to eat, eat not of, not what
the disciples brought, but the words of
the father, the words of truth that save
that woman." Jeremiah said, "Thy words
were found, and I did eat them." The
words of truth. We must love truth more
than our very physical existence or
subsistence. Truth. Is it true? I'm
going for it.
Is it true the seventh day of the
Sabbath? Yes, I'll do it. Is it true one
man, one woman in marriage? Yes, I'll do
it. Is it true I should not lie, but I
won't lie. Is it true? And how do you
determine it's true? It's biblical. You
must love the truth and you must believe
the truth.
No one believes what he or she hates.
So, you love it and you believe it.
Ultimately, you're talking about Jesus.
To believe Christ is to believe the
truth or to believe the truth is to
believe Christ. I am the way, the truth.
Very serious issue. You must love the
truth. And as I said earlier, many
people love the the the church. But do
not love truth. Truth gets them upset.
But they love church.
It's not love of church that saves you.
It's love of the truth. And that truth
is personified in Jesus Christ himself.
Love it. Obey it. love Christ, obey him.
If you love me, obey me. If you love the
truth, obey it.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Amen. I see we have a couple questions
already on from YouTube.
>> Mhm.
>> So, I think the first question that was
posted here is from Kayla Vargas.
>> She asks, "How do I increase my devotion
and my prayer time with God? I cannot
pray more than five minutes."
She cannot pray more than five minutes.
>> I wonder if it's that's like at a time.
I I'm not certain. But
>> perhaps she cannot kneel more than 5
minutes, but she can certainly pray more
than 5 minutes. You can pray when you
walk. You can pray at your desk. You can
pray while you drive. You can pray while
you're showering. You can pray 24 hours
a day. When you're handling a project on
your desk, you're talking to God to help
you. As you use your brain
persspiringly, you're talking to God.
Help me. Prayer is breathing.
So I don't understand how she can't pray
for just more than 5 minutes. Perhaps we
misunderstood what she said and God
bless her. Prayer is like breathing. Can
you breathe for 5 minutes only? No. You
pray all the time. You always talking to
God. Your children are driving you
crazy. You talk to God before you kill
them. You're always talking to God.
It becomes a lifestyle. It's a habit you
develop by practice, practice, pra
everything. You're stuck in traffic. You
talk to God. So there's no such thing as
I can only pray for five minutes. I can
only kneel for five minutes. Fine. When
the Bible says pray without ceasing, it
didn't say kneel without ceasing. Keep
this always in heaven. Talk to God all
the time.
>> He listen to you as though no one else
is alive. So we must continue praying,
praying, praying, praying. Talk to God.
Yes. Yes. In steps to Christ, you know,
prayer is talking to God as to a friend.
>> Yes.
>> All right.
>> Did that question have two parts or was
that it?
>> That was it. That
>> Okay. All right. Now, where's that
person from?
>> Uh I Well, Sister Kayla, you could
probably put in the chat.
>> Well, wherever the person is from, God
bless that country or that state or that
province or that region.
>> Amen. The next question is from
obedience better than sacrifice.
>> Yes.
>> Say it's possibly explained already. But
how can one grow in the grace and
knowledge of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ?
>> Study.
>> You study. Go to second Peter chapter 1.
>> That's exactly that was exactly the
passage that came to my mind as well.
>> All right. And case closed. Okay. Second
Peter chapter one.
>> Got to climb that ladder. Okay. Read the
verse one.
>> Simon Peter,
>> a servant and an apostle of Jesus Christ
to them that have obtained like precious
faith with us through the righteousness
of God and our savior Jesus Christ.
Grace and peace be multiplied unto you
through the knowledge.
>> Ah, wait a minute. Now, grace and peace
be what?
>> Multiplied unto
>> the question is how can I grow? Growing
and multiplication in that context are
the same thing. Grace and peace be
multiplied through the knowledge. So it
is by study that you grow in your
knowledge or there's multiplication of
understanding. Grace and peace be
multiplied through the knowledge. The
knowledge comes not by osmosis but by
study, study, study. It is in the study
of the word of God and obedience that
this multiplication, this growth
occurred. You cannot detour around study
of the word of God. Keep in mind the
entire universe was made by the word of
God. It is sustained by the word of God.
Jesus is the word of God.
The most intelligent decision you can
make is to live a life in harmony with
the word of God. But to have that
harmony, you must know what the word
tells you. That requires study. And if
you come to sticking point, remember
what God did for Daniel in Jer uh Daniel
8:16. And he said, "Gabriel, make this
man to understand division." God wants
you to understand. He will send not only
the Holy Spirit, he will send angels to
help you understand because they're also
involved in your spiritual life. And so
study, study is the word, the key word
and application. And it produces growth.
It produces growth. It improves your
spiritual immunity. You can resist the
infection of sin
>> and the things of this world cease to
appeal to you. You long for that new
world
where all is righteousness and there's
no sin.
Study
and obey.
>> Amen. Amen.
The next question is from remnant
messages states, I am a student.
>> How can I have a proper devotion time
whilst the school schoolwork needs
attention?
>> Yes, that's fine. That's fine. Keep in
mind all true knowledge comes from God.
God is the source of all knowledge.
You know many years ago I was a
counselor at a medical school and I
would talk to students when Christian
students came to me discussing you know
the burdens of all this study and all
this work. I suggested to them
while a grade is good but when you study
don't study just for grade study to
discover God. You're studying the
sciences biology physiology biochemistry
pathology you name it all having to do
with care for the body and healing the
body made by God. God's fingerprints are
in his creation. And so you look what is
the spiritual lesson in the fact that
the lungs are divided into bronchioles
or whatever else alvoli and and these
microscopic blood vessels and so small
only one blood vessel can blood blood
cell can pass through. Where is God's
fingerprint? You're looking for God as
you study. Let me tell you God will
reward your study. Listen to this
quotation from Christ object lessons
page 125 paragraph 3. [snorts] If the
believer of Christ will study his word
and practice it, there is no science in
the natural world. He will not be able
to grasp and appreciate. In other words,
look for God in God is to be seen in
biology, in anatomy. Somewhere his
fingerprint is there. Look for it. And
as you pursue that, the grades will
come. You do it diligently. Of course,
you don't slack. You don't spend time on
the basketball court and expect to pass
anatomy. No, you're studying, but you
have a different motivation. It is just
not a grade. It is I must come away with
a greater knowledge of God. I now have
some evidence that there's a God because
I studied anatomy and physiology, you
know, and whatever else. And so, as you
study whatever architecture, didn't God
give instructions for the building of
the ark? Didn't he make the universe?
Whatever it is, accounting, didn't he
talk about tithe and offering? Whatever
it is,
where is God's fingerprint in this
branch of legitimate knowledge? And I
use the word legitimate because studying
crime is not a legitimate branch of
knowledge. So I'm talking about
legitimate branches of knowledge. God is
the source of all knowledge. And the
fundamental principle of education is
not to get a degree, but to understand
God more clearly. Hey, I know that
sounds blasphemous, but we're talking
about a spiritual mindset. The
fundamental purpose of education is to
get closer to God. The fundamental
purpose of work is to glorify God as
your character develops. That's the
biblical perspective. And so, whatever
you're studying, do your best. Look for
God because God is involved in all
branches of legitimate knowledge. In him
is found all knowledge and wisdom. And
so you start your studies with God.
Another thing students need to learn to
do is prioritize. A lot of things we do,
we don't need to be doing. You see, they
take up our time. If God knew you needed
more time, he would have given you 27
hours in a day. But he gave all people
24. Whether it's Einstein or some
half-witted person. That's all you need
to do what you need to do. 24 hours a
day. We need to use time wisely.
Prioritize, cut out from our lives what
really make no contribution to our
spiritual development.
>> Amen. Amen. I'll just quickly read
Christ object lessons page 347 paragraph
1 in conjunction with what you said. His
law is written with his own finger upon
every nerve, every muscle, every faculty
which has been entrusted to man. And I'm
not that remote from being a student.
Remnant messages.
>> I was a student just seven months ago.
>> Yes.
>> I can't believe it's already been that
long, but seven months ago. And I will
say, do not be afraid to take time
before you start your day.
>> Have a talk with Jesus. That's right.
Say, pray. Read the word of God.
Firstly, it's verse. Pray without
ceasing and study.
>> Three questions,
>> Elder Ski, that you
>> offer to me. So, take time. spend with
God and your time will be multiplied.
>> He will multiply your efforts
>> in your studies
>> and bless your success.
>> Yes. Yes.
All right. Okay. Let me see if there are
any other questions here. I see another
question here on YouTube.
>> Okay. Obedience better than sacrifice. I
will just ask the question from Shanny
Shika since this person has not asked a
question. Okay. which is what advice
would you give someone who struggles
with praying and studying the word
>> who's who struggles with praying I
assume the person means the person is
not finding time to pray or to study
the Bible says in Luke 16:10 he that is
faithful in that which is least is
faithful also in much set yourself a
target let's say 10 minutes in the
morning with God do that for a
Try to increase it to 15 without adding
any unnecessary activities in your day.
Cut out unnecessary activities. You're
on a mission. You're not on a trip.
You're not on a sightseeing trip. You're
on a mission to study, get a degree. All
right. See if you can move it from 10
minutes to 15. After a while, 15 to 20
gradually. You know, Christian growth is
gradual. Christian decline is also
gradual. And so you try small
increments, but you must make that
effort. You simply can't sit on a
reclining couch and tell God, "Increase
my love for the word." You have to show
God that you really want to grow in
grace and in the knowledge. And so you
start small, something you can do. So
you have a sense of a mission
accomplished. I set out to spend five
minutes with God and I spent. So you
rejoice. You spent five minutes with
God. Five, increase that to 10. That's
not too much. And so you go in that
direction until you're spending some
time with God. That may surprise you,
not realizing I could have devoted this
much time to my savior first thing in
the morning. But as you said, my dear
Dr. Denanisha,
starting with God is the wisest decision
you can make. Let's say you're going to
school, you're studying architecture,
whatever it is, engineering. Don't run
away from the origin, the source, the
inventor of engineering to go study
engineering. Don't run away from the
inventive physiology to go study
physiology. If you understand what I'm
trying to say, he is the textbook, a
living textbook of every branch of
knowledge. And so gradually, gradually
increase your time with God and God will
bless you correspondingly.
>> But you must want to do it. You must
want to do it. It won't just happen. You
must try.
Yes. You
>> know Jesus said strive to enter into the
straight gate. Strive.
So you try to increase gradually and if
you do that you will increase it much to
your surprise and your spiritual
delight.
>> Amen. Amen. Amen. Amen. Now I see here
Katik. Katik boy. I'm sorry I'm not
pronouncing your name correctly likely.
uh your question is not necessarily on
the topic and we did discuss that uh
question in a previous episode called
preparation for the final crisis.
>> So I would direct you there
>> to that to the answer for that question.
>> Um I'm very sorry. Okay. So, just take a
look at that um clip and also take a
look at the Q&A that we did on probation
and we also did a Q&A on the second
coming of Christ.
>> Okay. So, those those clips will address
the question that you have.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> All right. And yes, Remnant messages, we
will pray for you. Uh this is the
student. Uh, I don't know if this is a
male or female, but the person says,
"I'm studying diploma in general
agriculture, but I feel like I'm wasting
time. What I want to study is the word
of God and become a preacher." Well, you
can preach wherever you are.
>> Let me talk to that person if that
person is still listening. If your deep
desire is to preach, why are you
studying agriculture?
You know, I was some a country somewhere
and I met this man young guy. He was in
law school. [snorts] He said, "I want to
talk to you." I said, "Fine, let's
talk." He said, "Uh, I'm doing well in
law school. Uh, but that's not what I
want to do." I said, "What do you want
to do?" I said, "I want to preach." I
said, "Why are you in law school? Why
aren't you in some Bible school or some
seminary? Why are you in law school?"
"If you want to preach." On another
occasion, I met a young lady. She's
studying sciences. Why? Well, her mother
wants her to be a doctor or father or
cousin or somebody. I said, "What is it
you want to do?" And she said, "My
passion is to be a Bible teacher." I
said, "Why don't you go study the
Bible?" and she dropped out, went to
study the Bible, went to some seminary,
got a masters in religion, and then she
became Bible worker for a conference.
And several years later, she saw me. She
said, "Do you remember me?" I said,
"No." She said, "I'm whoever." I said,
"Oh." She said, "I want you to know how
happy I am. I did exactly what you said
and I am a happy person. If you want to
be a preacher,
go study to be a preacher.
Why suffer through agriculture or you
know astronomy or whatever you want to
be a preacher. Go study to be a
preacher. What's your p primary urge?
There are a lot of miserable people in
school because they're doing what they
do not want to do.
If you want to be a doctor and
ofthalmologist
go study of themology.
Don't study knitting, study
orthalmology.
Whatever you want to be and is legal and
legitimate in God's eyes, go study that.
Now, let me say to someone listening, if
you're studying dentistry and you're in
the the last month of your program,
well, finish it, of course, and then go
do your Bible work. Finish it. But if
you're in the first few weeks and you're
miserable, go and do what you want to
do.
I'm not promoting selfishness. I'm
promoting. God puts urges upon people.
He puts, you know, convictions.
Follow it prayerfully. Follow it. Don't
just suffer through a program in which
you have no interest.
>> Okay.
>> Amen. And Kayla Vargas, just to close
out, um,
>> clarify, true, I pray incessantly. I can
only kneel for five minutes. Okay.
>> Thank you for answering my pre question.
So that's that's it. We pray without
ceasing. We don't have to be on our
knees without ceasing.
>> Uh and David Mi uh we also spoke about
the 6,000 years I believe in preparation
for the final crisis. So I would direct
you to that video clip.
>> Now it is 4:00 brothers and sisters.
>> Yes it is. Time flies.
>> Yes. Time flies when you are having fun
in the word of God. Amen. Amen. Thank
you, Elder Ski, for sharing freely of
your time, answering these questions
passionately and from the word of God in
complimentary passages from the spirit
of prophecy. Thank you for being direct
even as John the Baptist was direct and
[clears throat]
>> direct. Yes, can lose your life for
that, but be direct.
>> Let no one walk away confused. I said
this is sin. That's what I said. I said
you're wrong. That's what I said. I said
Jesus is divine. That's what I said. Let
no one be confused. Be direct. Don't be
harsh. Be direct.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> By the way, if someone listening to us,
you need to make a decision to get
baptized, make that decision. I get
baptized out of expression of total
devotion. We're talking devotion to your
savior. If you need to be rebaptized and
you're convicted that way, make that
decision. But whenever you whenever you
listen to the word of God, make a
decision. What did they say that
affected me at a personal level that I
need to make a decision? I need to study
more. Make that decision. Act on it.
Don't just listen and leave. What
decisions do I need to make as a result
of having listened to this Q&A? Always
think like that. Or this sermon or read
this book. What decision do I have to
make? What is God requiring of me? Did
he set up this Q&A just for me that I
might realize I need to take this step?
If the conviction is upon you, take that
step.
>> Amen. Amen. I'm very sorry. I missed
some questions here on Zoom. I was only
looking at
>> Were they connected to what we're
discussing?
>> Ah, I see. At least I just read through
one. Looks like it's connected.
>> Okay. Well, I guess this is how we treat
our body as Christians. We are
encouraged to live healthy lifestyles
and care for our bodies as temples of
God.
Well,
I don't know if this one is quite
I we can address that question,
Christian, in a different episode. I
think the next one here, can we ever
have enough of Jesus or can we ever get
to the point in our walk with God when
we will have enough of him? This is
>> no no.
>> When the Bible says grow in grace,
there's no point where that growth ends.
If you're developing the character of
God and God is infinite, you can never
stop growing because you cannot exhaust
infinity. So become more and more and
more like God, never becoming God
because you can't become God, but you
become more and more like God. And so
you don't become you don't reach the
point where you've had enough of Jesus.
Never.
If you're saying to yourself, I've had
enough of Jesus, you're in a lot of
trouble.
Amen. Amen.
All right. All right. Well, I have a
thank you here from Sister Rosemary
Elazan.
>> All right. Pastor SK,
>> Sister Janisha from the Philippines.
>> The Phil Oh, that's my second home. The
Philippines.
>> Yes.
>> I love the Philippines. I've been there
21 times.
>> Wow.
>> Love the Philippines.
>> Wow. Well, tell I said salamat poor for
her greeting.
>> Okay. Yes, m I guess Dr. Rosemary, I see
you have your hand raised. Do you want
to respond with a greeting? You can
unmute yourself.
>> God bless her.
>> Okay, I guess that was an accident. We
also have I think brother
uh I'm not pronouncing the name
correctly but our friend that had the
question on the events that are to
precede probation the close of probation
>> is joining from Namibia.
>> Yeah.
>> He's from where?
>> Namibia.
>> Oh Namibia. Vinhook
Swakupund.
Walus Bay.
Uh God bless Namibia. I love Namibia.
I've been there three times. Very hot
country. mainly desert, the Nid desert,
but a lovely country. God bless Namibia.
I really mean that. I miss Namibia.
>> Amen. And we have Sister Amanda Wallace
joining from the UK.
>> Oh yes, that's my sister Amanda and
Denny. God bless you, Amanda. God bless
you, Denny. Those are my friends online.
God bless you. Bless you. Bless you
wherever you are in the United Kingdom.
Yes.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> All right, friends. I won't be able to
reach everybody, but to those of you
that have joined on Zoom, YouTube,
YouTube, uh Facebook, and Instagram,
thank you for your presence and your
interaction today.
>> We truly want to be closer with the Lord
and commune with him constantly
>> and bring every thought into captivity,
bring it into subjection to the
obedience of Christ.
>> Yes, indeed.
>> You make that decision today. Once
again, Elder Ski, thank you for your
time and pleasure, expertise, for your
study. Amen.
>> And many thanks to my attorney Kashi for
also giving of her time freely to assist
in co-hosting this program.
>> And of course, how can we go without
thanking God?
>> Yes.
>> Who's given us the opportunity to
commune together and to learn of him in
this relative time of peace? Because
soon there will be a time when we will
not be able to host Zoom messages like
this. We won't even be able to go to
churches. We may just go house to house.
>> So let us thank God for the time we have
now. Yes. Yes.
>> So we will close out. Dr. Oichi has sent
a song that I would like for us to
share. This song is when praise demands
a sacrifice.
So what do we play this? Okay.
>> Yes.
[music]
[music] The call to go to Mount Mariah.
came [singing] to Abraham.
But the offering placed before [singing]
the Lord was not a lamb. [singing]
He bound his only son.
And as the knife was raised, [singing]
a sacrifice
became the prize of praise. [singing]
When praised demands a sacrifice,
I'll worship even [singing]
then,
surrendering
the dearest things [singing]
in life.
And if devotion costs me all, [singing]
he'll find me faithful to his call.
and [singing]
praise
demands a sacrifice.
[singing]
The call to go to Calvary
had come to God's own son.
But an altar waited for [singing] the
lamb he would become.
His hands reached up to heaven.
[singing]
And as the cross was raised
and with his life
he paid the price
of praise.
When praise demands a sacrifice
I'll worship even [singing]
then
surrendering
the dearest things [singing] in life.
And if devotion costs me all, [singing]
he'll find me faithful to his [music]
call. When praise
demands a sacrifice,
God hears the words of praise we lift.
Yet I have found. [singing]
He's done and more by what I'm willing
to lay down.
>> [singing]
>> When praise demands a sacrifice,
I'll worship even [singing]
then.
Surrendering
the dearest things in my life. [singing]
And if devotion [music]
costs me all,
he'll find me faithful to his call. When
grace
demands a sacrifice, [singing]
I'll worship him. [singing] Even then
surrendering
the dearest things in my life.
And if devotion costs me all, [singing]
he'll find me faithful to his goal.
Oh, when brave
de
a sacrifice.
[singing]
[music]
Amen.
Okay, there we go. Now you can hear me.
Amen. And amen. When praise demands a
sacrifice.
>> I am actually trying. Oh, there we go.
There it is. There we go. When praise
demands a sacrifice. Thank you so much,
Dr. Oichi, for sharing that song. May we
be willing to give up our lives for God
if that is what he requires. And that's
what he wants. He wants our entire
lives. And it may not mean dying, but it
may be giving up the very thing that we
hold most dear.
>> We must be willing to prize God prime.
All right, brothers and sisters. I look
forward to seeing you next. Stay tuned.
God willing, March, let me just give you
the date. God willing, March 28, we'll
be having a testimony with brother
Israel as he shares his story of faith.
So, thank you all for your time. May the
Lord bless you. And then April 4th, God
willing, at 3:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time, we have another Q&A with Elder
Randy Ski on Satan's last day
deceptions. If you notice, these are
topics from the book,
>> Last Day events, okay? Because we are
living in the last days and we need to
be ready. So, I look forward to seeing
you then. So yes, brother Christian, we
will have another program, God willing.
Same time, same place. Take care
everyone. God bless. Thank you. And
Elder Skate, give give Sister Skate my
love and regards.
>> I will do that. I'll do that.
>> Thank you. Thank you. And thank you,
Mom.
Yo, my mom will be celebrating her
birthday, God willing, next week,
Wednesday. So I praise God for my mom's
love, her ministry, her prayers.
>> 21 or 22? Ah, [laughter]
let me hold on. Let me add my mom. There
you go.
>> That is good.
>> 55. 55. Praise the Lord. [laughter]
>> All right.
>> Amen.
>> Goodbye.
>> Goodbye. Take care everyone. And thank
you, brother Emmanuel, as well. God
bless. God bless.